you bumped and you you ran into a fire
hydrant this we talked with our friend
tark in San Francisco yeah and was like
yeah check that out
goosh ran right into a fire hydrant I
can't feel good got it [ __ ] my knees
well fire hydrants don't have a lot of
give you mean no I mean that's not her
if she's not fire hydrant like kind even
when the car hits it kind of say 500
pounds or something crazy dirt stickies
yeah there's the thickest thing out
there yeah they're all cast-iron you
don't wanna know about that gunshot
after our last show where you know we're
in the green room good mood there's a
broom like there the windows are open to
the street we're all playing have a good
time playing grab-ass and reg1 just
Stalin right inside the disco [ __ ] right
the bay area very normal you know what I
saw one was so excited about my show
there's it going yeah it was like going
commander it was these Russians going so
how do how about what I did what I do is
I because I'm naturally having my
default is to be a hero I go get down
and I threw my spotty on rhiannon on me
I saved him you kicked that girl with a
blonde a sweat move [ __ ] move [ __ ] and
it all on me get ready get down down get
the money bad jump fell on me fell on
you
I owe my entire career to him you felt
it he can't die no if he goes I go I
said that if he goes my career screw to
no I said that part he goes there's no
fire in the kid man come on there was
like dude calm down
yeah I got a little I got a little I
know I would it look like I was saving
you that's what happen you get my
brother in the face with mmm
and then there was nothing it was
actually a blow back in the car so we're
fine but we figured out your real
motives and it was all right listen man
I got bills bro I hear you man you keep
running the business no I do
maestro put the mic no it's always if
it's a hot if it's hot and late yeah
it's a bad combo calm but in my man a
little bit hot late drinking yeah yeah
little fidgety there was a causative I
was watching you from the balcony and
there was a guy in front of me and he
smelled like weed he was laughing she
was like he loves that pistol people
always dying I was like this guy's
[ __ ] like you'd go like this you'd be
in the between jokes and he'd go like
this he go Jesus he whined I was he's
got motive
maybe covering up
I was like dude you got a [ __ ] calm
down thank God he was sitting up in
shock oh my god it'll be tracked it's
like who brought the hyena sir muzzle
you're a hyena please that's crazy
that's some lady at the mean greet try
and suck on my neck
really now was she missing all her teeth
yeah maybe she was Brody she was was she
hammered sure her man's gonna use I'm
dude I'm so sorry yeah I'm so sorry
there's always at least one time every
other weekend where a drunk very
depressed housewife will grab my don't
grab my tom
yeah well reach out go gank yeah I could
have a few me to me yeah boy like let me
take it a picture and then they reach
down like oh no we can't do that you
know it was sucked on my neck on come on
come on dude yeah like yeah would you do
that to anybody else what he's sucking
on my neck Wow cuz she wanted some of
that neck neck you brought up the funky
day in her even though she has no teeth
so she's always thirsty for blood when
she just can't get it when she tries to
get her teeth in it sounds like good
they're good
you know this all you do is he get
gummed by the door no you know it feels
like you know those fish that suck on
the tank that
Algie they're like black but they just
suck all day that's what she was
punished by the vampire council she
probably broke some vampire rule and
they let their teeth and he pulled her
teeth and actually haha you're really
funny yeah I used to have one of those
as a kid suck suck suck that's what she
looked like suck on the snack cool you
remind me of a fish I owned as a kid
hmm do you know what that suck all the
[ __ ] off the side of the tank you look
like that he looked like a sucker fish
they're cool man you'd have them they're
just like little they just whack your
tank for your cue
they just stand they got in the algae oh
that's all they do if you had like three
of them your tank was clean all the time
and no one [ __ ] them that's all they do
is suck the city's gonna win an Oscar
for this that's the rumor I want some
chompers like his bro these are my
favorite kind of movie I can't work my
fav so long trailer huh is this the full
movie or cuz I'm all set
Wow it looks great by seeing it now it's
too long the trailer don't look good
yeah me too man it's gonna be sick I
think greatest frontman of all time all
time right I think the greatest voice in
rock and roll and I think the greatest
frontman of all time better than Robert
Plant better than the lead singer of
journey did the second best voice or
maybe tie is
Steve Perry but I don't even think Steve
Perry had the voice that Freddie Mercury
had III don't think you know Danny
they'd look very silly you put those
they're the same they have the same line
what is it called so that they don't not
unschooled I forgot to say this they
brought a donut truck where they make
the donuts from scratch and they're on
Santa Monica
psycho santa monica psycho sidecar is
that what it is yeah hold on
yeah notes do them oh it's this another
four five years here it's the butter and
butter and salt this late to every gay
dude Oh Mikey Donnie come not in a
sidecar right he goes like cart don't
stop Santa model he goes wait amazing
Santa Monica Santa dies are those Levi's
those nice make yeah that's yes a wes is
into shoe that's a sidecar that's it's
the best I've ever had in my life well
you know by the hands dude every other
donut holes yes I freaked out though
that today they were making them guys
that have brought that truck on my
[ __ ] set and that he was and I go I'm
not eating to us and she was rolling
Mountain and the woman had looking I
tried it that Bradley Cooper yes it is
the cinnamon what the cylinder that what
are the best holy [ __ ]
GameChanger I'm freaking out donut oh my
god the best it's so good the best
donuts I couldn't take it looks so good
[ __ ] blue star to get a subtle they can
all suck my dick compared to that that
one - that's the huckleberry yes it is
some [ __ ] I'll because I want that right
now and they were hot I'm talking too
loudly but I freaked out yeah so I've
been going for five years so it's
whatever Dave Frank well let's go to and
watch Frank not eat doughnuts you'll be
like I don't bring her your diet all the
time still it's not really consider it a
diet I just don't eat doughnuts and I
buy them for my kids on the weekend what
do you what do you eat just like lettuce
and jerky or some [ __ ] no I know grains
dude I
ketose tell Elliot when I was getting
ready to fight Nogueira in Brazil I was
out there months before to do PR and
they flew me Forrest Griffin who was
fighting and Silva so there's the two
Americans and someone drove by I forget
how Balu in the favela out there which
yes that's where I was just thought I
mean the hood of the hood yeah and
there's guys with huge ak-47s and like
this is grand operated by the the gangs
of garzillo like yeah beat watch your
P's and Q's here man i fir doing
something there and I when I saw you
were handing out weren't your hand hold
on so I was in there and it was just
like kids are doing jiu-jitsu under
and their backs are all [ __ ] up and
there barefoot doing high kicks and I
just like what the [ __ ] and they're not
eating I felt so bad for him I said I
got to do something man and they got the
American where it's like no you don't
you we're not going back in here man
he was like I'm telling you be in
trouble and then the Brazilian who's
with us goes no everyone in this favela
respects Brendan because he's a fighter
right he's coming to our land to fight
our legend he's gonna highlight what we
do right because he he he can do no
wrong here no one's gonna hurt him right
then he goes put the crew not so much
right they don't know you guys right
Brendan's gonna be good so they had to
bring all Brazilian crew with me right
and we went in there and delivered
gloves and shin pads yeah but but I
didn't feel even when went in there like
you feel younger the roughest of the
rough in Brazil no I felt loved I felt
like yeah there was a sixth episode it
was Brazil I was in Rio de Janeiro but
what happened was we could not the
episode a couple of things happen we're
just it did we couldn't get it out in
time right so I spent all my time in the
favelas plus I was with Hobson Gracie
right
I was with Hoecker Gracie I was with
what's-his-name from Lucca Italy Bay who
beat who fought Grigson on the sand in
1980 oh Jesus olds oh he's amazing I
wrestled with him on the beach where he
fought Hickson who did yeah yeah
remember that and who else was I was
with and then I was with Jose Aldo and a
days team I was with that whole team and
I trained there for a few days so my
point being I was in the favelas and we
followed one of the story lines with a
gym in the favelas that trained all the
kids for free to take to teach them all
Jitsu and I wound up spending a couple
days there and having lunch there and
dinner there with these guys and it was
the same thing they couldn't get enough
of me because hey I love jiu-jitsu and
and I could I you know they they knew
who I was meeting with right and I was
giving back to them a sense of ownership
of something so here they were in the
favelas and we were there to kind of to
kind of talk them up to highlight it and
that's all they have a lot of people
don't realize it Frank Frank was
training with Hicks and Gracie for
Europe hit some Gracie and purple
a long time you train with him why don't
you walk in well Halloween night but he
deal all the merch like we did no he's a
sister that changed my brother and when
I'm with them I go hey brothers
well hey brothers yeah did he just say
what do you say about my sister that did
your sister that looks like your brother
that's actually not sure you I'm just
kidding man so he's loud really no sir
by school every day and the kids are
come from the older school you picked up
first and they would come and my brother
and all the friends and I throw my
notice wait taller than me short hair
carried a baseball glove with very short
that well she was obviously did she have
a dick I had a conversation with Joey
Diaz that would conversation with Joey
Diaz you're just on his podcast right
but I come say to enjoy Diaz I watch the
special degenerates on Netflix and I
called them to tell cuz I was listening
on Rogan and I said what makes Joey Diaz
so special you're in the same kind of
category is your guys's memories did
your memory to be able to go back
remember certain details about your
childhood and all the stories that's
what makes you guys such great comedians
like joy Diaz or drop a story he's never
heard before
anybody got [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah 82 I
was in and you're like an 82 yeah like I
can win him foil an 82 but then he'll go
her name the guy who sold him the
sandwich yeah exactly what he bought at
the sandwich place what he didn't get on
his sandwich what that guy said to him
then his buddy's out cycling name all
the guys and he's going through it it
just hit me like [ __ ] man his memories
so ridiculous
wonder how that happens to people why
they need that like way don't get
punched in the face like I remember yes
I didn't get that makes a dad
I don't know any details if you asked me
what year you and I met I wouldn't have
a [ __ ] clue Rogan is really good at
it too but different cuz you and Joey
can go back the rolodex and like a
always a master but you're getting good
Theo but and you'll you'll say something
and it'll trigger something in my
childhood [ __ ] I remember that and it
helps me with my [ __ ] yeah but listen to
Joey I'm like [ __ ] and I I call my dude
your special is so good man your memory
is you have the best marry anyone I know
you would if you gave what if Brian
worked as your memory and sat on your
shoulder and just told you all your
memories of your past and like let me
hold everybody's monsters if you keep
losing weight and you keep gaining
weight it could happen okay thirty times
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a gif it's a gift
it's a gift